[Music]
Mamma Mia here I go again ma'am oh oh hi
ah yeah good morning John it's uh
Tuesday August 21st yeah
you're not the only one that needs a
haircut you know I kind of love that
game you're playing yesterday
even Adam played it a little a Leo too
it goes like this were you just talking
and then you're talking and you're
talking and you're talking and you keep
talking your hair is getting much much
bigger oh my god I look like Julia
Roberts from Steel Magnolias is this how
they did her hair to make my hair do
that all I have to do is this just
around in a circle and then oh it's like
static electricity if it's not it's just
the way my hair works I know I need a
haircut when it starts to invade ah my
ears see that going on right there John
and I both sort of have the kind of hair
that goes out for the most part it
doesn't go down it gets bigger instead
of longer thanks dad but there is one
area where it doesn't grow out it goes
in and that is the ears down off the
sideburns and then curls back into the
ears and I know that if I were to grow
my hair you know shoulder length or so
that my hair would burst impede my
hearing and then at about like mid-back
I'm pretty sure that it would kill me
would be in my brain like garlic like
Devils snare Devils snaring into my ears
and around my brain and and I have to
like lumus Solem ah but it wouldn't work
because there's no way to get light into
my brain and it would it would be over I
would die it would be over for me
because of my hair so I have to keep it
trimmed
it's not just a matter of hygiene in my
my rugged good looks I firmly believe
that I get haircuts in order to save my
life and that is the only way that I can
pay someone $20 to do basically what I
believe to be an exorbitant grooming
ritual that is not of any practical
value something that I've been wanting
to talk about nerdfighters it's strange
situation because I know that we're not
supposed to necessarily be jokes but we
kind of are jokes
the nerdfighters are nerds but they're
also paid a loss and the fact is the
nerdfighter Center the universe is at a
place called winner this thing's kind of
strange how nerdfighters who used to be
like the bottom of the downtrodden
masses are now totally the joke cysts of
the jokes to finish off this video I
think when I mention that I think I may
have done permanent damage to my hair
that is not necessarily a bad thing just
possible that I may have prevented it
from doing its nasty evil brain ear
invading activities which could come in
extremely handy if there's some kind of
scissor apocalypse and all the scissors
stopped working because of the aliens
no that wasn't funny anyway I'll see you
tomorrow